eu chief orsoler fonder lion is set to
announce an even greener new deal to cut
emissions
she has the backing of a long list of
ceos and investors who say europe must
avoid the worst effects of climate
change
and secure a sustainable competitive
economic recovery
critics argue the plan will cut jobs at
a time that the pandemic is already
hurting the economy
aiming for zero emission electric cars
if the latest plans from brussels come
to fruition
the automotive sector will have to race
to meet climate protection goals
the european commission's green deal
foresees a 55
drop in eu greenhouse gas emissions by
2030.
up to now the goal was 40 and by 2050
europe is to be the world's first
climate neutral continent
that means the german car industry has
to clean up its act
the problem is that its best-selling
products the large luxury cars are still
running on combustion engines
the sector wants longer grace periods to
make the switch
and tolerance for other forms of power
alongside electric
otherwise say german car makers there'll
be massive
job losses julia poliskanova joins us
from the sustainable transportation
campaign group transport and environment
will europe become the first climate
neutral continent
and and will it be a success
well we certainly hope so look transport
today
is the largest climate contributor in
europe
and actually emissions from new cars
grew for years as car makers were
selling
heavy and polluting suvs so it's really
time
to invest in future proof technology
future-proof technology is the one that
will bring jobs
and make sure that our mobility is zero
emissions for our citizens
for our cities and for everyone else
when will it get
to the point that electro mobility is
zero emissions i mean so
so much of that electricity that is
generated
for those batteries and for those cars
still comes from
coal-fired power plants
in fact already more than half of
europe's electricity today
is low and zero carbon and today
uh the commission president will also
announce plans to drive
even more renewables into our system
even on today's figures an electric car
is already
three times better than an equivalent
diesel or petrol
so that myth must be put to rest so
we're on the road to
to a greener future but what's going to
happen to germany's more than
800 000 car jobs
look higher climate ambition is not
synonymous
with job losses in fact ultimately what
matters for the car industry
is that is that there is a healthy
demand for their products
and this year has shown that there is a
soaring
demand for electric cars more than 10 of
all sales in germany this year were
actually electric
so ultimately it's actually the
future-proof technology and it is
this demand that the car industry has to
meet so we must have higher co2 targets
so that the car industry invests in the
future technology
while else to having a clear european
plan
and support for the automotive
transition for the workers so that they
are ready for the future
skills today's investment
is this the right time i was going to
ask for for an even greener
plan from from the commission the
pandemic has already hit the labor
market hard
in fact what we saw is that electric car
sales were doing better than
other car sales during the pandemic and
especially as people saw what air
quality can be like in our cities
they don't want to go back to polluting
cars there are actually
waiting lists for electric models here
in europe
chinese models are coming to the market
that means that european car makers are
failing to meet that demand
and that demand is the future market for
them
um the demand you're talking about
electorate mobility so much
and there are so many other options out
there shouldn't the commission be
looking at
more than just that
absolutely and the commission is looking
at more than just that
in fact electric cars emission-free
vehicles are only one
part of the solution later this year we
will be working on a wider sustainable
mobility strategy
to make sure that there are less cars in
our cities that cars
are shared that fleets go electric that
freight
l still goes to clean uh solutions
there's more rail
so there's a vast amount of solutions
but ultimately when it comes
to the car and its technology beyond
cities
there will be cars and those cars have
to go
emissions free today the best technology
to do that
is electric we'll have to leave it there
you'll be apolis konova thank you very
much
thank you